i'm greg jarboe and what is that I mean
what we're going to talk about in this
first module of a content marketing
foundation course is liberally content
marketing I okay what is it so content
marketing is not a new concept it's been
around for over a hundred years in fact
one of the classic foundation stories of
you the birth of content marketing goes
all the way back to the Michelin
brothers in France and the Michelin
brothers you know in case you haven't
done your history that's okay you know
we'll refresher right now were two
brothers who made pneumatic tires and
they were trying to sell them along with
an innovative product at its time called
the automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my god what was worth going out
there for you know or Paris that's all
happening here and what the Michelin
brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more tires they had to get people
to drive farther and farther and use
them so what did they come up with the
concept that really is the birth of
content marketing in my book was the
Michelin Guide and the Michelin Guide
was unique in that it reviewed
restaurants not just restaurants nearby
in Paris but restaurants out there in
the provinces and the Michelin brothers
are the ones who came up with the one
two and three star rating system to say
this restaurant I know it's way out
there it's you know bad roads but guess
what to die for their ratatouille oh you
you got to have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way as since we're
going to give you a guide and you have
to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way which
hotels you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the
I just in case you have to how to repair
a flat tire particularly if it's a
Michelin tire because it cement
pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair and guess what that put
Michelin on the map why they weren't
trying to sell you more tires they
weren't telling you about the features
and benefits of round or a tire repair I
mean that was in there but it was only a
how-to article not necessarily a feature
of benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to their audience about
what their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900 was food
and by creating content but got the
audience to get into their new
innovative automobile and drive all the
way out there into the provinces for
that absolutely remarkable three-star
restaurant people got more flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the way michelin sold
more tires so that that's a great story
every time you sort of you know hit a
pause I'm like well we're doing content
marketing and we need to come up with a
concept bang back to the Michelin Guide
it's it's great foundation so let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century when it comes to
content marketing well you can read the
slide here and read the definition and
some people like reading definitions I'm
not going to read it to you but I am
going to highlight a couple of words in
the definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any definition of
content marketing the content that you
create needs to be relevant and it also
has to be valuable now if it's not
relevant then you're not actually
meeting my needs or interests you know
and why would I be interested in and
we've gotten way too tired of screening
out the commercial that comes on
you know trying to sell us snow tires
and pardon me we live in Florida I don't
use the tires what the left act is this
commercial going you know interrupting
what I'm watching
so relevance is important relevance
means that this content isn't going to
get screened out and the valuable the
valuable can can work in a lot of
different ways it can be interesting it
can be useful you know value is an
interesting proposition all by itself
but that's the key to content marketing
it's not just creating more spam it's
not just throwing more trash over the
fence and hoping something happens this
is something where if you created
valuable and relevant content you know
what your customers will find you that's
a whole different kind of proposition I
know there's some skeptics are saying oh
come on come on come on content
marketing is just a fancy new name for
social media marketing right and the
answer is well there is some overlap and
we're going to deal with that in module
3 but let me just be clear here social
media content is part of what content
marketing needs to create but it can
also create content for your website and
that's not the social media it can also
create content that your PR people can
share with reporters or bloggers and
that's meant normally considered social
media content and by the way all of that
content can be optimized so maybe it
actually as part of SEO not social media
marketing in fact that's the other place
that content marketing really overlaps
and it's not coincidental it so happens
that around February 2011 when Google
rolled out the first of its multiple
versions of the Panda update all of a
sudden even SEO s started to pay
attention to content marketing why
because Google
change the rules and what Google
basically said is if your content isn't
valuable or relevant you know what it's
not going to rank very well in our
search algorithm and all of a sudden
people who had been used to like putting
keywords in the right places realized
content matters you mean I've got to
actually tell stories that are
interesting I've got to create
information that's valuable yeah you can
make it relevant
that's the optimization part but you
know if you're trying to optimize a
piece of boring irrelevant trash god
bless you good luck so yeah content
marketing has grown it's like tripled in
terms of web search interest since the
Panda update and that we're talking
about Panda 1 of course there was Panda
2 Panda 3 panda 4 I mean come on Google
is driving us in this direction and so
content marketing it's pretty relevant
today now one of the other things that
people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you understand I do b2b
content marketing or I'm a small
business or part me I'm an enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right well possibly maybe on
occasion so let's just question that
assumption for a second you know content
marketing has been around now long
enough and enough people have done it
but some research has been conducted and
it's been conducted against b2c
marketers and b2b marketers and small
business marketers and enterprise level
marketers and when they start asking key
questions like ok we're going to try to
determine what is the difference between
an effective content marketer and an
ineffective content marketer let's see
the results well first of all the most
important thing to be an effective b2c
content marketer is you need a
documented content strategy ok all right
mean people who are we
aren't as effective as people who
actually have thought about this written
it down got it okay no great insight but
you know interesting to note secondly
they've got to have somebody in charge
who oversees content marketing oh Lord
does that mean we have to have a reorg
or maybe we just have to designate
somebody who reports to somebody else
whatever but guess what it really helps
if somebody is driving this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics then they're
less effective peers and this is not an
argument more is better this is just
partly that's way the data falls out the
people who are actually more effective
are doing more different kinds of things
a broader range of tactics and who knows
maybe it's that broader range that's
part of the success formula same thing
is true with social media platforms the
effective content marketers are using
more than the ineffective ones and last
but not least and this may be a sort of
a result of the first four by gosh
effective content marketers generally
have greater percentage of the overall
marketing budget in their organization
Wow okay that's the b2c marketing for it
but you don't understand I'm going to be
to see marketer yeah okay so let's take
a look at the b2b content marketing
formula guess what you need to have a
documented content marketing strategy to
be an effective b2b content marketer you
need to have someone who oversees
content marketing strategy it helps if
you are using more tactics and more
social media platforms and guess what
you spend a higher percentage of your
overall marketing budget on content
marketing
well that's similar to the b2c content
marketers but you understand b2b is
different yeah there's a couple small
differences but guess what
overall the top five criteria are
similar and when you get the small
business here's what you're going to see
same five criteria and you're an
enterprise I know the world is different
for enterprises actually not so much so
four different data points
let's net it out ah there's a pattern
and the pattern is is I don't care what
flavor of Content marketer you are you
can be b2c b2b you can be small business
you can be large enterprise at the end
of the day there are five things that
you've got to focus on if you want to be
effective we've already covered these
and are there differences between small
businesses and large enterprises between
b2b and b2c well sure but they are all
at the margin what's the downside if we
don't do this you know as anyone going
to come in and like whack us any answers
um maybe not inside your boardroom but
it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your salespeople makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair and the men in the
chair actually refers back to a classic
McGraw Hill ad campaign from I think the
1960s but basically the guy in the chair
asks theoretically some questions from
quote maybe your sales person okay
I don't know anything about you I don't
know about your company I don't know
about your company's product I don't
know about your companies you know
reputation or anything about you and so
what was it you're going to try to sell
me and that's the downside of not having
a content marketing program we've
actually found in work that we've done
with companies that content marketing
can shorten the sales cycle why you're
providing people with information at key
points that they need in order to take
the next step so yeah is there downside
sure stick with the status quo struggle
swimming against the tide you know what
it's probably smarter to have a content
marketing program
so this introductory module in the
content marketing foundation try to ask
and answer these questions what is
content marketing and oh by the way just
how different are b2c b2b small business
and enterprise content marketing and I
think you've got the answer
content marketing means that your
content needs to be relevant and it
needs to be valuable and by the way that
content can come in a whole lot of
different forms it's not just words on
paper it can be videos
it could be infographics it can be
webinars it can be speeches that your
executives are giving in public you know
content can take a lot of different
forms but at the end of the day you want
to be an effective content marketer and
for that we're going to go through five
more modules and let me give you a sort
of a highlight of what we're going to
cover guess what we're going to cover
all the things that makes you effective
we're going to cover content marketing
strategy you need a documented one so
we'll go through that and by the way
we're going to have little extra bonus
because it's a problem that we've seen
people encounter again and again which
is all right before we've ever done this
in my organization I need to get a
budget for like a pilot project how do I
do that
what do I do when I don't have a budget
I'm trying to start up content marketing
in my organization so that's going to be
covered in module 2 module 3 we're going
to talk about someone who oversees
content marketing Yeah right the org
chart and what we're really going to
focus in then this happens more in
larger enterprise than other
organizations but even smaller
businesses some day aspire to be
medium-sized businesses and many in size
businesses want to grow up to be large
enterprises so you know what it's
probably useful for all of us to
understand where this is headed and
we'll talk about the lack of integration
across the marketing mix both within the
organization but also
when it comes to communicating to
customers and why guess what maybe it's
time to organize a little differently
third we'll talk about all those content
marketing tactics and instead of just
listing them all because you know what
lists are are interesting but they're
not persuasive what we're going to look
at are the content marketing tactics
that content marketers consider most
effective so that one is down the list
and you're going to want to take some
time and we're not just the broad range
of things you could be doing but the
ones that seem to move the needle and
then then we'll tackle the sort of
subsidiary question of how do I produce
a variety of content you know that seems
to be a problem for some folks will
trust me once you get your handle your
arms around the hole what is effective
the variety of content pretty much takes
care of itself in the fifth module we're
going to take a look at social media
platforms and again content marketers
are experimenting with a wide variety of
them the list seems to change daily as
new ones are introduced or suddenly the
the list is revised because some social
media platform just got acquired but now
the company that acquired it is you know
pretty big and pretty interesting so
maybe we need to pay attention to that
too well guess what once again we're
going to do a little triage here we're
only going to look at the ones that seem
to be most effective today and you too
may want to experiment with other ones
beyond that what it helps to have is a
core part of your content marketing
programs the ones that are the most
effective and then guess what the
challenge is not having one the
challenge is actually producing engaging
content or those social media platforms
so we'll look at that in module 5 and in
module 6 we're going to talk about
budgets why because it all comes down to
the budget you got to have one and by
the way you need to be spending a larger
percentage of your marketing budget on
content marketing in order to be
effective in order to do that
we're gonna have to skin this cat we're
gonna have to look at measurement we're
gonna have to get you over the hurdle of
how come it is so hard to measure the
effectiveness of my content how do I
know that when when can I turn around
and show that to the top management so I
can say wow that moved the needle fine
you need a bigger budget next year you
got it so that's what's coming stay
tuned strap in this is gonna be a bumpy
ride at times but guess what it is a
journey worth taking Hey want to become
an expert in digital marketing then
subscribe to the simple learn Channel
and click here to watch more such videos
turn it up and get certified in digital
marketing click here